Nous allons donc entrer maintenant dans le chapitre 7.
Après s'être longuement arrêté dans le chapitre 6,
nous abordons maintenant le thème structurant de toute cette épître,
un thème que l'auteur, comme vous le savez, a longtemps voulu retarder.
Il a abordé ce thème au chapitre 5, et puis à cause de la lenteur des auditeurs,
il a fait une parenthèse qu'il a refermée pour ensuite y rentrer maintenant dans le chapitre 7.
Et avant de se lancer dans ce chapitre 7, on va avoir besoin aujourd'hui de faire une introduction à ce chapitre 7,
même si on va se plonger dans ce verset 1.
Mais comment répondrez-vous à cette question ?
Quel est l'objectif de l'épître aux Hébreux ?
Ou même quel est le thème de l'épître aux Hébreux ?
J'espère que vous savez et que vous avez compris dans cette série de prédications sur l'épître aux Hébreux
que le thème de l'épître aux Hébreux, c'est la supériorité et l'excellence du ministère de Christ.
Mais quant à l'objectif, quel est l'objectif ?
Pourquoi l'auteur a écrit cet épître ?
Pourquoi l'auteur a voulu publier la gloire de Christ devant les yeux des auditeurs ?
Eh bien, l'objectif ultime par l'exposition de la gloire de Christ, il nous est donné au chapitre 4 et au verset 16.
Au chapitre 4 et au verset 16, nous est donné l'objectif ultime pour le chrétien.
Approchons-nous donc avec assurance du trône de la grâce,
afin d'obtenir miséricorde et de trouver grâce en vue d'un secours opportun.
Voilà l'objectif ultime de cet épître, que chaque chrétien puisse vivre une vie d'assurance,
que chaque chrétien puisse vivre une vie de confiance,
et marcher avec zèle, avec courage,
marcher avec une vie triomphante,
marcher comme les grands héros de la foi ont marché avant eux,
marcher avec un pas pressé,
se tenir debout et marcher jusqu'à l'aurore,
où nous voyons déjà la lumière luire.
Est-ce que c'est la façon dont nous évaluons notre vie ?
Sommes-nous satisfaits de la façon dont nous vivons notre vie chrétienne ?
Sommes-nous satisfaits de notre marche ?
Est-ce que notre marche est caractérisée par un zèle audacieux pour le royaume de Dieu ?
Est-ce que notre marche terrestre est caractérisée par une assurance, par une confiance ?
Et voilà l'objectif de l'apôtre,
que nous puissions nous approcher avec audace,
avec assurance du trône de la grâce,
et vivre une vie triomphante.
Parce que l'audace, la confiance et le courage,
eh bien il semble que les Hébreux en manquaient,
à l'heure où l'apôtre, qui est probablement l'apôtre Paul, leur écrivait.
Et la source de ce découragement,
lorsque l'apôtre écrit à cette église découragée,
les sources de découragement sont nombreuses,
qu'on comprend largement dans cet épître.
Et non seulement elles sont nombreuses,
mais en plus ces sources s'allumentent les unes les autres, malheureusement.
Premièrement, les Hébreux étaient tout simplement fatigués de combattre.
Les Hébreux faisaient partie de cette première génération de chrétiens,
des Juifs, issus du judaïsme évidemment,
qui ont contemplé la gloire de l'Évangile,
qui ont pour la première fois découvert toute la clarté de l'Évangile,
l'accomplissement des prophéties au sujet du Messie à venir,
dans la personne de Jésus.
Et ils y ont appliqué leur foi avec joie,
avec euphorie presque, peut-on imaginer.
Et on peut imaginer ces Hébreux
qui découvraient quelque chose de tout à fait nouveau,
eh bien en parler à leur famille,
en parler dans leur synagogue,
en parler à leurs voisins,
essuant quelques indifférences,
mais en continuant.
Et essuant quelques mépris,
quelques moqueries,
mais en continuant.
Et ces Hébreux, il nous a dit qu'ils ont tenu bon,
et qu'ils ont continué, eh bien,
de s'accrocher à leur profession de foi.
Mais les injustices qu'ils ont commencé à rencontrer
ne se sont pas arrêtées.
Ils ont rencontré de premières injustices,
puis elles se sont accumulées progressivement avec le temps.
Ils ont tous été chassés des synagogues.
Ils ont, pour la plupart,
le chapitre 10 nous dit,
vu leurs biens être ôtés,
les biens qu'ils avaient légitimement acquis,
à cause de leur profession de foi.
D'autres encore ont vu la persécution aller plus loin,
puisque le chapitre 10 nous dit
qu'ils ont été mis publiquement en déshonneur,
publiés publiquement à l'opprobre.
Et l'auteur ne dit pas exactement,
concrètement,
comment ils ont été mis,
peut-être par pudeur,
comment ils ont été publiquement mis au déshonneur,
mais nous pouvons voir que les tactiques de Satan
n'ont pas changé pour essayer
de décourager une Église d'avancer dans sa profession de foi,
par la menace de la honte,
par la menace des moqueries du monde.
Et voilà ce que ces Hébreux ont connu.
Lorsqu'ils ont commencé à partager leur expérience,
eh bien,
ils se sont fait certainement accusés de trahison.
Trahison par rapport à leur tradition familiale,
trahison par rapport à l'enseignement de leurs parents,
trahison par rapport à même l'ethnie, à la nation.
Et certains d'entre nous, je le sais,
ont connu aussi ce type de persécution dans leur propre famille.
Pour certains qui ont changé d'Église,
ou même qui ont changé même de religion,
vous pouvez peut-être, eh bien,
appréhender la difficulté de ce que les Hébreux ont connu.
un déchirement des accusations de trahison.
Mais quelque part, le tiraillement que les Hébreux ont connu était un tiraillement tout à fait unique.
Parce que non seulement ce qu'ils,
la foi qu'ils professaient, eh bien,
semblait être une trahison de leur tradition,
mais encore plus,
le sacerdoce, c'est-à-dire l'ordre de prêtre,
le temple contre lequel, maintenant,
ils ne devaient plus reposer leur confiance,
avait un fondement biblique.
Donc c'est une chose pour nous,
de subir la persécution
et de se détourner de la religion de nos pères
lorsque leur pratique se confronte directement à la parole de Dieu.
Mais ça en est une autre pour les Hébreux,
de se détourner de leur religion,
de leur rite religieux,
lorsque le fondement même de leur pratique religieuse,
c'était la parole révélée par Dieu lui-même.
Le tiraillement des Hébreux était unique dans l'histoire.
Et ils venaient à en être découragés.
Ils regardaient des années plus tard à leur vie.
Ils regardaient en arrière
toutes les relations qu'ils avaient perdues,
tous les biens qu'ils avaient perdus,
leur vie marquée par la difficulté
et probablement par la tristesse.
Et peut-être que cette question venait maintenant dans leur tête,
à quoi bon ?
Est-ce que cela valait vraiment le coup ?
Est-ce que je n'ai pas été trop radical
sur des différences qui, finalement, sont un peu mineures ?
Est-ce que cela valait le coup de perdre tous ces biens ?
Lasser du combat.
Une deuxième source du découragement
était leur manque d'assurance.
Et évidemment, je ne vais pas rentrer en détail dedans
parce qu'on l'étudie bien dans l'Épître aux Galates,
mais lorsqu'ils ont commencé à regarder à nouveau
l'ancienne sacrificature,
ils ont été tentés à nouveau d'essayer d'extraire la justice de la loi
et d'essayer d'obtenir l'approbation de Dieu
à nouveau par des rites,
à nouveau par les œuvres de leur chair.
Et il est normal qu'une telle personne
qui se met sous un tel système religieux des œuvres
ne peut pas aboutir dans l'assurance,
ni dans la joie,
ni dans l'assurance de son salut éternel.
Et ne peut marcher avec confiance ici-bas,
avec l'espérance promise qui a été scellée.
Il est plutôt marqué par le doute constant,
par la vision d'un Dieu contre lui,
plutôt marqué par un manque d'assurance
et un manque d'audace.
Une autre source qu'on pourrait citer,
c'est tout simplement que les Hébreux
ont été freinés par le péché.
Lorsqu'ils ont découvert Jésus-Christ,
ils ont été émerveillés.
Et le cœur a été ébahi
de voir comment toute l'histoire
s'articulait pour la révélation de Jésus-Christ.
Comment tout l'Ancien Testament
avait enfin du sens.
Et ils se sont empressés
de chérir Christ par la foi.
Mais le chapitre 5 nous a dit,
lorsque nous l'avons étudié,
qu'ils ont fini par considérer
la doctrine comme quelque chose
de peu utile dans notre vie pratique.
Et voilà une tentation
tout à fait contemporaine.
Les Hébreux ont commencé
à se satisfaire des enseignements fondamentaux
et à rejeter le fait
d'être enracinés dans la parole de Dieu.
Non, la vie chrétienne,
c'est quelque chose de simple.
On n'a pas besoin d'étudier tant que ça.
Je suis sauvé par la foi
et ça me suffit.
Le chapitre 5 décrit
exactement la tentation
dans laquelle les Hébreux sont tombés.
Oui, autrefois,
on était dans quelque chose
de sophistiqué,
de mystérieux
dans l'Ancienne Alliance.
Maintenant,
c'est une relation simple
et nous n'avons plus besoin
de nous enraciner
avec comme les théologiens le font.
Et ils ont commencé,
comme certains le font encore aujourd'hui,
à déconnecter la connaissance de Dieu
de la vraie spiritualité.
La vraie spiritualité,
c'est les miracles.
C'est une foi aveugle.
Ce n'est pas l'enracinement
et l'étude de la doctrine.
Le chapitre 5 nous dit
exactement l'inverse.
Et le chapitre 5 nous dit
non seulement,
évidemment,
que la vraie spiritualité
ne peut pas s'arrêter
à la connaissance,
sans quoi nous serions
des hypocrites,
mais la vraie obéissance
s'appuie sur la connaissance
de Dieu.
Et ce qui est dit
dans le chapitre 5
que nous avons longuement étudié,
c'est que
leur désintérêt
de la doctrine
n'est pas resté
sans conséquences.
Ce n'était pas simplement
qu'ils avaient un rapport
neutre à la doctrine.
c'est que cela a produit
dans leur cœur
une aversion aux doctrines.
Ils commençaient
à froncer les sourcils
quand quelqu'un lui parlait
de théologie.
Ils commençaient
à ne plus
certainement étudier,
à ne plus méditer,
mais cela a produit
dans leur cœur
une incapacité
de discerner
le bien et le mal,
comme nous dit
le chapitre 5.
C'est-à-dire
qu'ils n'étaient plus aptes
à discerner
ce que Dieu aimait
et à être en harmonie
avec ces choses,
et ils n'étaient plus aptes
à discerner
ce que Dieu détestait
et à être en harmonie
avec ces choses,
de sorte qu'ils ne marchaient
plus dans des voies
de justice.
Voilà,
mes frères et sœurs,
l'état de cette Église.
Et peut-être,
dans une partie
ou une autre,
nous pouvons nous reconnaître.
Fatigué,
las de la difficulté
de la marche chrétienne,
manque d'assurance,
ou même
freiné par le péché
à cause de notre manque
de connaissance.
Et donc,
comme je l'ai dit,
le but de cet Épitre,
c'est maintenant
de dire aux chrétiens
marchez avec assurance.
Approchez-vous
du trône de la grâce
avec assurance,
avec confiance.
Comment l'auteur
va-t-il faire
pour encourager
une Église abattue ?
Et on peut se poser
la question aujourd'hui
comment les Églises font
pour encourager
des personnes abattues ?
Quelle prédication
les pasteurs vont prêcher
pour encourager
des Églises abattues ?
Quel est le traitement
biblique du découragement ?
Par un discours motivationnel
pour vous rappeler
votre préciosité
et toutes les choses
que vous pouvez acquérir
sur ce monde ici-bas ?
Non.
Est-ce que c'est par
un concert de louange
où l'apôtre suggère
« Faites un concert de louange
où vous allez demander
au Seigneur
un souffle nouveau
dans votre vie ? »
Ce n'est pas
le traitement biblique.
Comment l'apôtre
va maintenant
dans ce chapitre 7
traiter le découragement
que je viens de décrire
des Hébreux ?
Par l'enseignement
des Écritures.
Melchisédech.
Chapitre 7, verset 1.
Et tout le chapitre 7
que nous allons étudier
dans certainement
une longue série
de prédications,
tout le chapitre 7
est une prédication
basée sur le verset 20
du chapitre 6
qui est lui-même
une citation du psaume
que nous avons lu
en introduction.
Dans cette discussion
entre Yahvé et Adonai,
l'Éternel dit à mon Seigneur
« Je te promets,
tu es souverain sacrificateur
selon l'ordre de Melchisédech. »
Et ce chapitre 7
est un enseignement
des Écritures.
Dans quel but ?
Afin que le peuple de Dieu
soit exposé
à la gloire de Christ
et il trouve une motivation
pour marcher avec assurance.
Voilà le traitement
biblique
du découragement.
Est-ce que tu es sûr
que c'est ce dont j'ai besoin
ce matin ?
Tu ne connais pas ma semaine,
ni les mois,
ni les années que j'ai connues ?
Moi, j'ai plutôt besoin,
je ne sais pas,
peut-être d'une prédication
où je vais être secoué
ou au contraire,
j'ai besoin d'une prédication
où je vais être...
mon égo va être...
je n'ai pas le mot,
mais mon égo va être caressé.
Excusez-moi,
je n'ai pas le verbe,
mais vous avez compris l'idée.
La réalité,
c'est que nous sortons
tout juste d'un chapitre 6
dont la tonalité
est plutôt marquée
par des avertissements
envers le chrétien.
Et merci Seigneur,
l'épître aux Hébreux
ne s'arrête pas
au chapitre 6.
Comme pour dire,
les avertissements
et même la chaleur
des flammes de l'enfer
ne suffiraient pas
aux chrétiens
pour créer en lui
une motivation durable
pour marcher
dans ce pèlerinage.
Même si le plus grand
des prédicateurs
vous ferez sentir
la sévérité de Dieu
et son jugement,
cela n'a pas
la capacité
de produire
dans le cœur
du chrétien
durablement
une motivation
nécessaire pour marcher.
Et voici le chapitre 7,
la gloire de Christ.
Autrement dit,
ce dont nous avons besoin
pour rejeter le péché,
pour marcher
avec audace
et assurance,
ce n'est pas tant
ultimement
les avertissements
de l'enfer.
ce n'est pas simplement
des exhortations
à abandonner
vos péchés,
à vous débarrasser
de la chair.
Non.
Le traitement
de l'apôtre ici,
c'est de remplacer
une affection
par la chair
par une affection
encore plus grande.
L'affection
de notre sauveur
Jésus-Christ.
Et que l'amour
que nous avons
envers ce tendre sauveur,
ce cher sauveur
qui nous a aimés
avant que nous l'aimions,
ce cher sauveur
qui s'est donné
alors que nous étions
encore ses ennemis,
qu'il puisse combler
notre cœur
et chasser
toute autre tentation.
Voilà le traitement
biblique
du découragement.
Non pas
en vous exhortant
d'abandonner
vos habitudes,
votre vie païenne,
non,
en présentant
la gloire de Christ
pour que nous puissions
être submergés
par son amour
à nouveau.
Maintenant,
et nous devons
faire confiance
dans le traitement
de Dieu,
dans la façon
qu'il a de nous
encourager à nouveau.
Et nous abordons
donc ce chapitre 7
et je suis obligé
de commencer
avec quelques remarques
sur ce personnage
mystérieux
des Écritures.
Et sachez que
dans l'Ancien Testament,
toutes les
les occurrences
relatives à Melchisedec,
nous les avons
lues en introduction.
Autrement dit,
il y a trois versets
dans toutes les Écritures
dans l'Ancien Testament
qui parlent
de ce personnage mystérieux.
seulement trois versets.
Qui est ce Melchisedec ?
Et l'histoire,
même au sein de l'Église,
a proposé plusieurs hypothèses
et je ne vais pas régler
la résolution de cette hypothèse
dans cette prédication.
Je pense que
les autres prédications
où l'apôtre se sert
de la présentation
de Melchisedec
vont nous aider
à bien comprendre
qui est ce Melchisedec.
mais il y a plusieurs hypothèses
que l'Église a soulevées
vis-à-vis de l'identité
de ce Melchisedec.
Premièrement,
certains ont dit
que c'était un ange
qui apparaissait à Abraham.
Un ange mystérieux
qui se ferait appeler
sous le nom de Melchisedec.
D'autres ont suggéré
que c'était
le Saint-Esprit lui-même.
Une théophanie du Saint-Esprit
qui se présenterait
à Abraham.
D'autres ont suggéré
de façon historique
qu'il s'agissait plutôt
de Sème,
l'un des fils de Noé lui-même
qui a vécu,
on le sait,
une très longue vie
et sa vie
pouvait coïncider
avec,
il pouvait être
un contemporain d'Abraham.
Et il reçoit
ce titre honorifique
de roi de Salem
et de prêtre.
Mais disons
que ces trois hypothèses
n'ont pas été
les plus retenues,
elles ont été plutôt minoritaires
dans l'histoire
de l'Église.
Il en reste deux
qui sont les plus probables.
La première étant
que Melchisedec
est le Christ préincarné.
Melchisedec,
dans l'Ancien Testament,
c'était Christ préincarné
rencontrant Abraham.
Comme on peut le voir
dans d'autres passages
de l'Ancien Testament
et nous allons voir
dans d'autres prédications
comment cette thèse
est compréhensible
et peut être soutenue
par d'autres versets
du chapitre 7.
Mais je pense,
selon mes recherches,
que la position majoritaire
au sujet de Melchisedec,
c'est que Melchisedec,
parmi les milieux orthodoxes,
c'est que Melchisedec
était un véritable homme,
le véritable roi de Salem,
dont il est dit
très peu de choses
dans les Écritures,
à raison,
comme on va le voir,
et qu'il agissait
comme un type de Christ
envers Abraham.
Non pas que c'était
le Christ préincarné,
c'était un homme
qui agissait
comme un type de Christ.
Et donc,
tout ce chapitre 7,
mes frères et sœurs,
c'est une prédication
au sujet,
comme argument fondateur,
Melchisedec.
Et donc,
une prédication écrite
de l'apôtre
qui mêle
exégèse biblique,
herménotique,
qui mêle
application christocentrique,
application personnelle
pour le chrétien.
C'est vraiment
un modèle
pour tous ceux
qui essayent
de travailler
des prédications.
Nous sommes devant ici
une prédication écrite
de l'apôtre
magistrale
où l'apôtre
va enseigner
le peuple de Dieu
la typologie biblique.
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire
par là ?
C'est-à-dire
comment Dieu
dans l'Ancien Testament
a révélé progressivement
son plan de rédemption
par des ombres,
par des types
qui annonçaient déjà
ce que Jésus
allait faire
ou Christ lui-même.
Donc,
l'apôtre ici
est en train
de donner
des clés
aux auditeurs
pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre
l'Ancien Testament
dans son ensemble,
pour que l'Ancien
Petit Testament
ait du sens
et pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre que,
mais oui,
en fait,
dès l'Ancien Testament,
cela était au sujet
de Jésus-Christ.
Jésus-Christ
n'est pas une nouveauté
néo-testamentaire
ou de Esaïe.
Jésus-Christ
est le cœur
de l'histoire
et le fondement
de l'histoire.
et il est déjà
présenté
dans les premières pages
du premier livre
de la Torah
par des ombres,
directement après
la chute.
Nous pouvons voir
des ombres
et des types
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
et ce n'est pas
à nous d'aller chercher
quelle est l'ombre,
quel est le type.
L'auteur ici
le fait pour nous,
de façon inspirée
par Dieu,
nous expliquant
le rôle de Melchisédech
selon ma compréhension
aujourd'hui.
Melchisédech
est un type
de Christ.
Mais ne soyons pas
confus
et ne cherchons pas
à faire de cette prédication
quelque chose
de plus mystérieux
qu'elle l'est.
N'essayons pas
de creuser
différentes hypothèses
plus mystérieuses
les unes que les autres.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que le but principal
de ce chapitre
n'est pas de nous rendre confus.
Le but principal
de ce chapitre
ce n'est même pas
de parler de Melchisédech.
Le but principal
de ce chapitre
c'est de voir
comment ce type de Christ
a accompli
ce que Christ
dans toute la plénitude.
Autrement dit
tout ce que je vais dire
au sujet de Melchisédech
Christ l'a accompli
dans toute sa plénitude.
Comment l'Ancien Testament
manifeste
que Dieu
dès l'origine
avait préparé
cette transition
d'un système sacerdotal
à un autre
selon l'ordre
de Melchisédech
dont Christ
a été nommé
souverain
sacrificateur.
On va avancer
lentement
dans ce chapitre 7
et même ce verset 1
que nous allons étudier
aujourd'hui
nous ne pourrons pas
extraire
toutes les informations
de ce verset 1
mais nous pouvons
nous demander
ce matin
comment
dans cette rencontre
nous pouvons apprécier
la gloire singulière
de Jésus Christ
comme étant le
prêtre
du Dieu
très haut.
Je relis le verset 1
ce Melchisédech
était roi de Solemne
et nous n'allons pas
aborder sa royauté
aujourd'hui.
Il est prêtre
du Dieu
très haut.
Il alla
à la rencontre
d'Abraham
qui revenait
de la défaite
des rois
que nous avons lu
dans le chapitre
14 de la Genèse.
Dieu désire
mon frère et ma sœur
et chers invités
que chaque homme
et que chaque chrétien
s'approche
et vive
avec assurance.
Quittons
notre léthargie
comment
en nous présentant
la gloire
admirable de Dieu
et que nous puissions
marcher
en la saisissant.
Alors comment
dans cette rencontre
si brève
de l'Agenèse
pouvons-nous apprécier
la gloire
singulaire de Christ ?
Nous allons aborder
six points.
Premièrement
dans l'incontestable
gloire
de ce Melchisédech
prêtre du Dieu
très haut.
Deuxièmement
par la préexistence
de ce sacerdoce.
Troisièmement
par la médiation
nécessaire
de ce sacerdoce.
Quatrièmement
par l'étendue
supérieure
de ce sacerdoce
et enfin
par la provision
suffisante
de ce sacerdoce.
Premièrement
la gloire
de ce prêtre
du Dieu
très haut
était une gloire
incontestable
reconnue
immédiatement
par Abraham
lui-même.
Je ne vais pas
trop longuement
m'attarder
pour résumer
ce qui s'est passé
mais vous avez entendu
lors des offrandes
que plusieurs rois
se sont alliés
pour attaquer
notamment
le roi de Sodome
et ils ont vaincu.
Ils ont laissé
le royaume de Sodome
comme une terre
pliée,
une terre vaincue
et ils ont commis,
ces rois ont commis
toutes sortes
d'exactions
sur le royaume
de Sodome.
et non seulement
ils ont pillé
des biens
mais ils ont aussi
comme cela
était parfois
et ça
est toujours
d'usage
ils ont enlevé
des hommes
et parmi ces hommes
il y avait Lot
qui était
le seul membre
de la famille
qui avait suivi
Abraham
dans l'appel
que Dieu lui avait
donné plus tôt.
Et donc
il y a un messager
qui va voir Abraham
et qui lui dit
Abraham
il y a une guerre
dont tu ne fais pas partie
mais par contre
il y a ton neveu
qui a été enlevé.
Et là
Abraham se lève
constitue une armée
chasse les rois vainqueurs
et les met en déroute.
Et le terme original
suggère même
que cette bataille
qui a eu lieu
avec Abraham
était une bataille
sanglante
fatigante
éreintante
c'était le massacre
des rois
pas simplement
la défaite des rois.
Abraham a mené
une guerre réelle
une guerre fatigante.
Et Abraham
était déjà reconnu
donc
comme une personne puissante.
Les chapitres 13
et le chapitre 12
nous dit
qu'il était déjà riche
Abraham.
Donc la grandeur
d'Abraham
n'est pas démontrée
dans ce passage
ni dans le livre
des Hébreux.
Les Hébreux savaient
qu'Abraham
était déjà
un homme puissant.
C'était un chef de guerre.
Parce qu'il avait
plusieurs hommes
qui étaient ses serviteurs
et qui sont partis
et ce n'était pas simplement
des serviteurs
c'était des gens
qui étaient capables
de mettre en déroute
des armées de rois.
Des hommes habiles
pour la guerre.
Mais encore plus
que cette importance
géographique
et territoriale
Abraham
il nous est dit
dans ce chapitre 14
de la Genèse
il est appelé comment
en verset 13
il est appelé
l'Hébreux.
et cela relève
d'une importance
théologique
capitale
parce que Dieu
dans sa révélation
en l'appelant ainsi
il est l'Hébreux
rappelle à son peuple
qu'Abraham
était
le bénéficiaire
de la promesse
de Dieu
qu'il allait faire
qu'à travers lui
il allait bénir
toutes les nations.
Il était la personne
qui a reçu
la promesse de Dieu
il était
le chef
de la tribu d'Israël
Israël était comme
caché en lui
il était le père
d'une nation biologique
et le Nouveau Testament
nous dit
qu'il est même
le père
de tous les croyants
car il a été pour nous
un modèle de foi
parce qu'il a été justifié
comme nous
par la foi.
Et donc
le texte de Genèse
est là
dans ces deux aspects
à la fois chef de guerre
et à la fois
l'importance théologique
historique
pour nous rappeler
l'importance d'Abraham
pourtant le chapitre 7
d'Hébreu
n'est pas là
pour nous rappeler
la grandeur d'Abraham
elle est là
pour nous rappeler
qu'il y a eu
un statut
incontestable
supérieur
à cet homme important
qui est Melchisedec
et le chapitre 7
est là
pour nous préciser
vous voyez
ce père de l'église
quelque part
le père de l'église
de tous les âges
et bien
il s'est soumis
à quelqu'un
qui s'est présenté
à lui
et qui avait un statut
de façon incontestable
supérieur à lui
qui préfigure
le chef
de l'église lui-même
si Abraham
est
le père
des croyants
et bien
il reconnaît
un chef supérieur
devant qui
il se soumet
et comment
cette supériorité
il la manifeste
nous avons déjà vu
des éléments
dans la Sainte Seine
comment
Abraham
reconnaît
non seulement
il est supérieur
à Abraham
mais comment
il est supérieur
au roi de Sodome
lui-même
le roi de Sodome
a vu lui
son territoire
être
pillé
et il vient
vers Abraham
et qu'est-ce qu'il est dit
il propose
d'offrir
des biens
à Abraham
que Abraham refuse
mais il est dit
quelque chose
au sujet
de la provenance
de ces personnes
dans Genèse 14
que nous avons lu
il est dit
dans Genèse 14
que
le roi de Sodome
se mit en route
pour rencontrer Abraham
vous voyez comment
vous allez voir
comment chacun des mots
qui est utilisé
dans la parole de Dieu
est d'une grande préciosité
c'est un trésor
que nous avons
entre les mains
et plus nous nous arrêtons
plus nous voyons
des étoiles
qui brillent davantage
mais le roi de Sodome
vint
à la rencontre
d'Abraham
c'est une chose normale
qu'on aurait pu attendre
du roi de Sodome
tu as perdu
tout est bien
tu demandes de l'aide
à quelqu'un
il vient te récupérer
tout est bien
et bien tu vas
lui remercier
et lui offrir
des présents
mais contrairement
au roi de Sodome
lorsque vous reprenez
le temps de lire
le chapitre 14
de Genèse
il n'est pas dit
de Melchisedec
qu'il vint
auprès d'Abraham
Melchisedec
semble se tenir
déjà là
devant Abraham
son royaume
n'est pas en guerre
normalement
on ne devrait même pas
attendre que le roi de Salem
fasse son apparition
son royaume
n'était pas en guerre
rien n'a été ôté
de son royaume
mais le roi de Melchisedec
se présente
et déjà
devant Abraham
et pourquoi cela est important
parce que
cela nous donne
l'impression
déjà dans le chapitre 14
de la Genèse
que Melchisedec
semble tomber
du ciel
devant Abraham
lorsque le roi de Sodome
se mit en route
Melchisedec
est présent
devant Abraham
dans un lieu
qui n'est pas son royaume
dans une guerre
qui n'est pas la sienne
et Hebreu
au chapitre 7
verset 3
qu'on va voir
dans d'autres prédications
nous donne ce sentiment
qu'effectivement
ce roi Melchisedec
semble tomber des nus
semble sortir du ciel lui-même
et faire son apparition
devant Abraham
et cette intention
est voulue déjà
dans Genèse
de la part
de Moïse
lorsqu'il rédige ce récit
si c'est Moïse
qui l'a fait
non seulement
leur provenance
est radicalement différente
l'un vient d'un royaume
vers l'autre
l'autre semble tomber du ciel
mais effectivement
dans la réception
des dons
Abraham manifeste
qu'il reconnaît
une gloire incontestable
devant lui
devant l'un
il va dire
non je préfère
refuser tes dons
parce que ce que
tu vas me donner
je vais t'être redevable
mais devant Melchisedec
Abraham ne se contente pas
d'accepter
le pain et le vin
il donne tout ce qu'il a
quelle réaction étrange
de la part d'Abraham
qui rencontre un homme
qu'il n'a a priori
jamais vu
qui rencontre un homme
qui n'a aucune part
dans cette guerre
à première vue
qui se présente
devant lui
et la réponse
instinctive
d'Abraham
je te donne
la dîme de tout
je refuse
le roi de Sodome
qui aurait pu être
des dons légitimes
mais voilà
un message
choc
pour les hébreux
voilà un message
choc
pour cette église
abattue
qui se rassemble
peut-être le dimanche
en disant
Seigneur change
mes circonstances
Seigneur intervient
dans ma vie
parce que je suis fatigué
et qu'est-ce que
l'auteur leur appelle
regarder le témoignage
de quelqu'un
qui ne se rapporte pas
envers le prêtre
du Dieu très haut
d'une façon intéressée
mais regarder le témoignage
d'Abraham
qui lorsqu'il est face à Dieu
ne se préoccupe
d'une chose
qu'est-ce que je peux lui donner
la dîme
de tout
et bien
voilà la réaction
du chrétien
lorsqu'il contemple
la gloire
singulière
quel message
choque pour les hébreux
qui avaient tant besoin
que Dieu agisse
dans leurs circonstances
rappelez-vous
que ce dont votre âme
a véritablement besoin
c'est d'être exposé
à la gloire singulière
incontestable
de votre Dieu
voilà la gloire singulière
dont l'âme du chrétien
a besoin
lorsqu'il entre à l'église
non pas ce que Christ
ce que Dieu
peut me donner
dans mes circonstances
je viens
parce que je vais demander
quelque chose à Dieu
mais premièrement
je viens
parce que j'ai besoin
d'être exposé
à qui Dieu est
voilà la disposition
que nous devrions avoir
lorsque nous ouvrons
les écritures
montre-moi Christ
renouvelle-moi
dans la beauté
de ta grandeur
renouvelle-moi
dans la préciosité
de ta parole
renouvelle-moi
dans les gloires
de notre Dieu
et je sais
que quand tu me parles
Seigneur
je sais que
quand je ressens
ta parole
qui traverse mon cœur
mon cœur
tressaille de joie
et c'est ce dont
j'ai besoin
ce matin
d'être
réfléchi
par la gloire
incontestable
du Dieu très haut
deuxièmement
comment pouvons-nous
voir la gloire
singulière du Christ
non seulement
par sa gloire
incontestable
qu'Abraham a vue
devant Melchisedec
qui est le prêtre
du Dieu très haut
mais nous allons
particulièrement
nous arrêter
dans ce verset 1
du chapitre 7
sur ce terme
prêtre du Dieu
très haut
et comment la gloire
singulière de Christ
peut être vue
dans l'utilisation
intentionnelle
de ces termes
Cohen
prêtre
les Heléliones
du Dieu
très haut
Cohen
les Heléliones
et bien nous pouvons
voir sa gloire
singulière
deuxièmement
par la préexistence
du prêtre
du Dieu très haut
un fait remarquable
dans le Genèse
chapitre 14
Melchisedec
est la première
personne
du récit biblique
à être appelée
prêtre
c'est le premier
personnage
qui est
explicitement
appelé
Cohen
dans la parole
de Dieu
et ce fait
est tout à fait
remarquable
même s'il y a eu
déjà des personnes
qui ont été
des types
de la fonction
de prêtre
avant Melchisedec
c'est la première
fois qu'un homme
est appelé
officiellement
prêtre
du Dieu très haut
et pourquoi cela
est remarquable
l'auteur se sert
de cet argument
pour rappeler
aux Israélites
aux Hébreux
avant même
l'institution
de Lévi
avant même
la grandeur
du sacerdoce
lévitique
vers lequel
vous continuez
à plonger
votre regard
il préexistait
un prêtre
avant lui
Melchisedec
préexistait
à Aaron
il existait
avant Lévi
avant ce tabernacle
il existait
avant ce temple
et il a été
rendu légitime
par cette appellation
prêtre
du Dieu
très haut
et voilà
la vérité
oubliée
du peuple juif
qui regardait
avec mélancolie
leur religion
de leur père
qui regardait
même peut-être
avec un certain
complexe
d'infériorité
la religion
de nos pères
elle est sophistiquée
elle est intellectuelle
elle est complexe
elle est mystérieuse
alors que notre
liturgie chrétienne
elle est très simple
qu'elle rappelle
pour ce peuple
qui ont tendance
à idéaliser
la complexité
de l'ancien sacerdoce
et à admirer
la sophistication
des rites religieux
rappelez-vous
peuple d'Israël
semble dire
l'apôtre
que le système
religieux
vers lequel
vous mettez
votre regard
et votre mélancolie
c'est un système
religieux
qui est relativement
récent
il y a eu
un ordre sacerdotal
qui existait
six siècles
avant lui
votre premier prêtre
dit à Aaron
que vous admirez tant
est intervenu
six siècles
après l'arrivée
d'un autre prêtre
que moi j'ai agréé
le prêtre
du dieu très haut
Melchisedec
et il est vrai
nous observons
même de façon
pastorale
ces tentations
que l'église
qui est ridiculisée
l'église
qui est persécutée
peut avoir
la tentation
de regarder en arrière
pour rechercher
une stabilité
dans des systèmes
religieux
plus rigides
dans des systèmes
religieux
qui semblent
plus stables
moins modernes
moins contemporains
mais si les hébreux
étaient tentés
par la vieille religion
qu'ils aillent
au bout de leur démarche
et qu'ils ne s'arrêtent
pas au temple
ni à David
ni à Aaron
mais qu'ils aillent
encore plus loin
vers le premier prêtre
qui a été institué
par Dieu lui-même
le premier prêtre
agréé par Dieu
Melchisedec
combien de fois
avons-nous entendu
nous protestants
comme attaque
envers notre religion
la vieille religion
c'est la vraie religion
et c'est vrai
mais que nous n'aboutissions
pas dans notre recherche
vers une haute liturgie
réformée
pour chercher
la vraie religion
que nous n'aboutissions
pas dans notre recherche
vers l'église romaine
que nous n'aboutissions
pas dans notre recherche
vers l'église occidentale
l'église orthodoxe orientale
que nous n'aboutissions
pas non plus
vers les juifs
et la complexité
de leur structure
mais que nous aboutissions
au prêtre
qui exista
avant tous les autres prêtres
et qui existera encore
lorsque tous les prêtres
des autres religions
seront morts
le prêtre
du Dieu Tréhaut
et non seulement
ce prêtre
du Dieu Tréhaut
a été annoncé
ordonné
agré par Dieu
avant les vies
mais ce que David
voit dans les cieux
c'est une discussion
supratemporelle
entre Yahvé
et Adonai
qui dit en fait
de tout temps
tu seras
souverain sacrificateur
à jamais
notre prêtre
est prêtre
à jamais
l'église du Christ
n'a pas à rougir
de la simplicité
de sa liturgie
et à regarder en arrière
en cherchant une stabilité
dans l'église catholique
qui propose
une structure
soi-disant plus stable
l'église de Christ
n'a pas à rougir
des critiques
de sa modernité
pourquoi ?
parce que le prêtre
de qui nous nous réclamons
est le premier prêtre
c'est le Christ lui-même
qui a été institué
prêtre
selon l'ordre
de Melchisedec
qui préexistait
à Aaron
et à Lévi
et à tous les autres prêtres
notre prêtre
est le prêtre
de l'église
de tous les âges
notre prêtre
est le prêtre
de l'église antique
notre prêtre
est le prêtre
de l'église du Moyen-Âge
de l'église
de la Renaissance
et de l'église
d'aujourd'hui
partout où elle se trouve
il est le prêtre
du Dieu Très-Haut
qui préexista
à tous les autres prêtres
il a la primauté
voilà l'assurance
dans laquelle
le chrétien
voilà l'assurance
que le chrétien
peut se saisir
son prêtre
est le seul prêtre légitime
il existera
avant
et après
la mort
de tous les autres prêtres
troisièmement
comment pouvons-nous voir
la gloire singulière
de Christ
au travers
de ce
Kohen
Léal-Élion
le prêtre
du Dieu Très-Haut
et bien nous voyons
la gloire singulière
de Christ
dans la médiation
nécessaire
du sacerdoce
qui est révélée
par ce terme
prêtre
du Dieu Très-Haut
qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par là ?
je vous ai dit
que c'était la première fois
que dans le récit biblique
un homme était appelé prêtre
mais c'est aussi
la première fois
dans le récit biblique
que Dieu est appelé
le Dieu Très-Haut
et cela aussi
revête
une importance
capitale
parce que ce terme
Kohen
Léal-Élion
rappelle aussi
la médiation
nécessaire
le prêtre
du Dieu Très-Haut
parce que le mot
Très-Haut
qui est pour la première fois
utilisé vis-à-vis de Dieu
est présenté
dans toute la ville
avec deux connotations
bien différentes
premièrement
le Dieu Très-Haut
pour ses adversaires
représente
un Dieu
avec un poids
de gloire
majestueux
et terrifiant
pour ses adversaires
et pour les incrédules
le Dieu Très-Haut
c'est le Dieu
séparé de sa création
le Dieu
inapprochable
très saint
devant
des pécheurs
qui sont
déclarés
ses ennemis
c'est un Dieu
terrifiant
le Dieu Très-Haut
c'est un Dieu
redoutable
nous trouvons
notamment
dans le psaume
Israël
qui tente
et qui provoque
qui ?
le Dieu Très-Haut
qui interviendra
comme un juge
Daniel au chapitre 4
qui est-ce
qui va délivrer
le jugement
contre le roi
Nebuchadnezzar
le Dieu Très-Haut
Lamentation
au chapitre 3
n'est-ce pas
la volonté
du Dieu Très-Haut
que viennent
les misères
et les maux ?
Le Dieu Très-Haut
est présenté
dans la parole
de Dieu
comme un Dieu
terrible
malheur
à celui
qui fait face
au Dieu Très-Haut
sans avoir
ses péchés
expiés
car il connaîtra
la colère
il connaîtra
la fureur
d'un Dieu
séparé
de sa création
il connaîtra
le grondement
du tonnerre
lorsque Dieu
fera vaciller
les cieux
et la terre
et lorsqu'il
secouera les armées
aucune armée
si puissante
soit-elle
ne pourra
se présenter
devant le Dieu
Très-Haut
aucune philosophie
aucun système
de pensée
si sophistiquée
soit-elle
pourrait désarmer
un argument
du Dieu Très-Haut
le pécheur
sera exposé
devant la lumière
du Dieu Très-Haut
aucune ombre
ne pourra le cacher
mais la parole
de Dieu
présente aussi
le Dieu Très-Haut
avec une saveur
douce
pour son peuple
qui est rentré
en alliance
avec lui
le Dieu Très-Haut
comme il nous est dit
par Melchisedec
lui-même
et par Abraham
qui va reprendre
ce terme-là
le Dieu Très-Haut
c'est aussi
le Dieu possesseur
de toutes choses
qui a créé
le ciel
et la terre
et non seulement
il possède
toutes choses
mais c'est le Dieu
pourvoyeur
c'est le Dieu
qui pourvoit
aux besoins
de ses enfants
et qui se présente
comme un père
à son peuple
voyez ces deux notions
de Dieu
elle et Lyon
Dieu Très-Haut
c'est le même Dieu
avec une relation
différente
dépendamment
de l'homme
devant qui il se tient
une relation
de jugement
de colère
effroyable
ou une relation
de filiale
entre un fils
et un père
de quoi va dépendre
notre relation
à ce Dieu Très-Haut
quel visage
du Dieu Très-Haut
rencontrerons-nous
après la mort
parce que c'est
une vérité
absolue
chacun d'entre nous
fera face
au Dieu Très-Haut
chacun d'entre nous
rencontrera
elle et Lyon
le Dieu Très-Haut
et de quoi va dépendre
votre relation
au Dieu Très-Haut
sur quoi avez-vous
misé votre destiné
éternel
la complexité
de votre
enfance
fera pencher
le cœur de Dieu
les traumatismes
que vous avez connus
vous misez vraiment
sur ça
pour votre rencontre
avec le Dieu Très-Haut
votre rigueur
dans les affaires
de cette vie
sur quoi misez-vous
cette rencontre
qui va déterminer
votre destiné éternel
la réponse
nous l'avons ici
notre rencontre
et notre relation
avec ce Dieu Très-Haut
dépend d'une chose
de notre relation
avec le prêtre
du Dieu Très-Haut
Coëlle
l'élelion
c'est lui
qui va nous représenter
ou non
devant la face
du Dieu Très-Haut
et lorsque Abraham
rencontre Dieu
dans les chapitres
12 et 13
et qu'il reçoit
les promesses
de Dieu lui-même
et bien maintenant
Abraham rencontre
le prêtre
de ce Dieu
le médiateur
entre Dieu
et les hommes
et lui-même
sur quoi avons-nous
quitté Abraham
nous avons quitté Abraham
qui reçoit
les promesses
chapitre 12
reçoit les promesses
de Dieu
et qui par la suite
fait quoi ?
Il pêche
il va en Égypte
il dit que sa femme
c'est pas sa femme
par quoi redise
par lâcheté
et sur lui repose
le risque
j'imagine dans sa tête
de perdre
toutes les promesses
que Dieu
lui a envoyé
et voici maintenant
qu'il rencontre
qui ?
dans sa peur
peut-être
dans son effroi
le médiateur
du Dieu très haut
le prêtre
du Dieu
très haut
voilà qui
voilà comment
nous pouvons voir
la gloire singulaire
de Jésus Christ
dans ce terme
il y a une médiation
nécessaire
que seul un homme
est venu accomplir
le prêtre
défini
du Dieu
très haut
et Abraham
a cette reconnaissance
immédiate
Dieu venait de lui parler
maintenant devant lui
se tient
son prêtre
maintenant
il a son prêtre
qui peut défendre
sa cause devant Dieu
Abraham comprend
que ce n'est pas
maintenant selon ses oeuvres
qu'il va hériter
de ses promesses
mais qu'il a un médiateur
qui se tient devant lui
et quelle
réponse instantanée
de la part d'Abraham
et maintenant
on comprend
pourquoi il vient
porter sa dîme
c'est bon
j'ai un représentant
entre Dieu et moi
j'ai le prêtre
Dieu de très haut
et lorsque je le rencontrerai
face à face
ce sera avec le sourire
au visage
que je me présenterai
devant lui
ce sera avec assurance
que je marcherai
dans sa présence
parce que j'ai un prêtre
du Dieu très haut
je ne peux
je ne pouvais m'empêcher
de penser à Jean-Baptiste
comme nous l'avons lu
dans l'introduction
de ce culte
qui de façon
incontestable
immédiate
lorsqu'il a vu
Jésus-Christ
s'était crié
voici l'agneau de Dieu
lorsqu'Abraham
voit ce prêtre
du de très haut
Abraham voit maintenant
cette médiation
l'agneau de Dieu
entre Dieu
et les hommes
et non seulement
il voit
le médiateur
entre Dieu
et les hommes
mais il annonce
par cette déclaration
prophétique
que ce médiateur
sera aussi le sacrifice
qui sera offert
l'agneau de Dieu
immolé
avant la fondation
du monde
nous dit Jean
combien cette gloire
singulaire
frères et sœurs
devrait réchauffer
nos cœurs
lorsque nous aussi
comme Jean-Baptiste
comme Abraham
nous avons entendu
la voix
de notre bon berger
et que nous avons
contemplé pour la première fois
la gloire
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
combien cela
rappelez-vous
a saisi votre cœur
a réchauffé votre cœur
et vous n'aviez
qu'une envie
c'était de vous donner
entièrement
de vous jeter
dans ses bras
et de marcher
à sa suite
voilà ce qui vous a
rendu capable
de vivre avec elle
l'exposition
de la gloire
incontestable
et lorsque vous avez
trouvé en Christ
votre refuge
cette médiation
nécessaire
entre Dieu
et vous
oui mes frères et sœurs
ceux qui auront
les péchés effacés
ceux qui entreront
avec assurance
avec largesse
dans le royaume de Dieu
ce sont ceux
qui auront mis leur foi
dans le prêtre
du Dieu très haut
qui est selon l'ordre
de Melchisedec
dont le sacerdoce
préexiste à Aaron
et Lévi
et qui a été déclaré
dans les cieux
par David lui-même
quatrièmement
par Dieu lui-même
contemplé par David
pardon
quatrièmement
comment pouvons-nous
contempler
par ce terme là
Cohen
Léalélion
la gloire singulaire
de notre Jésus-Christ
et bien par l'étendue
supérieure
du sacerdoce
de Jésus-Christ
Cohen
et
Léalélion
la façon dont
Melchisedec
est appelé
dans le récit
de la Genèse
est tout à fait
inhabituelle
prêtre du Dieu
très haut
habituellement
les dieux
et les prêtres
et les rois
étaient plutôt appelés
par rapport
à leur lieu d'origine
roi de Salem
roi d'Egypte
le dieu d'Israël
d'Abraham
et de Jacob
et d'ailleurs
on le voit
dans l'Ancien Testament
lorsque Dieu
se rapporte
à son peuple
d'Alliance
le peuple
de la nation
d'Israël
il se présente
en tant que Dieu
d'Abraham
d'Isaac
et de Jacob
en présentant
la vérité
que les bénédictions
vont être
circonscrites
à ce peuple
les bénédictions
issues de l'Alliance
qui vont découler
des sacrifices
vont être définies
limitées
au peuple
de l'Alliance
et les étrangers
les nations païennes
autour
sont appelés
des étrangers
même dans le Nouveau Testament
à l'Alliance
bien sûr qu'il y avait
des gens
qui se convertissaient
au peuple juif
mais ils devaient
quelque part
devenir eux-mêmes
juifs
selon leur rite
quelque part
mais la réalité
c'est que par cette
appellation
Dieu d'Abraham
d'Isaac
et de Jacob
l'une des choses
que Dieu
veut montrer
c'est que les effets
des sacrifices
sont limités
au peuple
de l'Alliance
et
en l'occurrence
ici
à une nation définie
le peuple d'Israël
que Dieu a choisi
parmi toutes les nations
mais ici
Melchisedec
n'est pas appelé
par ce titre-là
déjà parce qu'Israël
n'existait même pas
mais Melchisedec
est appelé
le prêtre
non pas du dieu
de Salem
lui qui vient de Salem
il est appelé
le prêtre
du dieu
très haut
autrement dit
il est appelé
le prêtre
d'un dieu
universel
le prêtre
d'un dieu
et d'un seigneur
de tous
les créatures
de tous les hommes
de toute la terre
et ce terme
El Elion
non seulement
rappelle comme nous l'avons vu
la médiation nécessaire
mais nous rappelle aussi
l'universalité
du sacerdoce
de Melchisedec
un sacerdoce
qui n'est plus
maintenant limité
à une seule nation
et lorsque ce prêtre
se présente à Abraham
on peut imaginer
l'étonnement
quelqu'un
pourrait même dire
l'arrogance
de ce prêtre
de se définir
du dieu
universel
lorsque moi
je présente
le dieu
de ma ville
avec mon humilité
mais cela rappelle
le culte
l'obligation
que le culte
soit universel
tous les hommes
ont été faits
comme des êtres adorateurs
nous sommes
des êtres spirituels
et il y a une attente
de dieu
envers la création
que l'être
l'adore en retour
c'est une réaction
tout à fait raisonnable
c'est une attente
de la part de dieu
parce que nous avons été
constitués
pour l'adorer
de sorte que
vous ne pourrez pas
et l'homme ne peut trouver
ni joie
ni paix
ni repos
ni joie profonde
que lorsqu'il retrouve
le but de sa création
glorifier dieu
prendre plaisir en lui
répondre au but
de sa création
et cela repose
comme obligation
sur tous les hommes
malgré le péché
cette attente de dieu
demeure la même
mais nous savons
qu'à cause du péché
à cause de la pollution
du péché
nous avons besoin
d'un médiateur
tous les hommes
ont besoin d'un médiateur
maintenant
pour adorer dieu
et donc ce prêtre
n'est pas le prêtre
du dieu de salome
il est là pour
préfigurer
un médiateur
qui étend
les bénédictions
de dieu
sur toutes les nations
et non comme
Aaron
simplement
à une nation
ethnique
voilà l'introduction
d'un sacerdoce
universel
dans la rencontre
avec Abraham
dieu
va bénir
toutes les nations
de la terre
à travers
un prêtre
de cet ordre
voilà ce que dieu
annonce Abraham
par cette rencontre
par le prêtre
du dieu très haut
dont le sacerdoce
est maintenant
universel
et pour tous
ceux qui étudient
la théologie
vous savez que
genèse 12
genèse 15
genèse 13
sont des chapitres
on est en terre sainte
quand on lit
ces chapitres là
les promesses de dieu
qui descendent d'Abraham
et le chapitre 14
qu'on a lu
semble être un peu
une parenthèse
à première lecture
pourquoi cette rencontre
pourquoi cette guerre
alors que le chapitre 12
et 13
et 15
sont si riches
en théologie
et on peut s'y arrêter
jusqu'à la nuit des temps
mais ici on a une guerre
et une rencontre
avec un homme
mais laissez-moi
vous proposer
la raison d'être
de ce chapitre 14
dans le raisonnement
de l'auteur biblique
pourquoi ce chapitre 14
de Genèse
et cette rencontre
avec Melchisedec
est tout à fait en lien
avec la réception
des promesses
qu'Abraham a reçues
vous vous rappelez
de cette promesse
qui a été donnée
à Abraham
je bénirai ta descendance
et à travers toi
à travers ta descendance
toutes les familles
de la terre
seront bénies
quelle promesse
vertigineuse
pour Abraham
qui n'a même pas d'enfant
à travers toi
toutes les familles
de la terre
seront bénies
Abraham
comment pouvait-il
imaginer une seule seconde
que ça allait vraiment se passer
lui qui n'avait pas de fils
et même s'il avait un fils
comment ce fils là
pourrait bénir
toutes les nations
de la terre
et même s'il avait
une postérité
nombreuse
généralement
vous connaissez
dans l'histoire
et même dans les récits bibliques
lorsqu'on a une famille
nombreuse
l'importance
elle est plutôt mise
sur notre
importance militaire
les grandes familles
sont des familles puissantes
des familles
qu'il faudra craindre
mais ici
ce n'est pas ce qui est dit
Abraham
tu auras une postérité
qu'on ne pourra pas compter
mais ta postérité
bénira
toutes les familles
de la terre
par quel canal
je vais pouvoir bénir
toutes les nations
de la terre
même si j'ai une famille
nombreuse
comment elle pourra
être la bénédiction
ou être le canal
de bénédiction
envers les familles
de la terre
chapitre 14
Abraham
rencontre
le prêtre
du dieu
universel
autrement dit
Abraham
rencontre
un homme
dont la fonction
première
est d'étendre
les bénédictions
qu'il reçoit
de dieu
aux familles
des nations
Abraham
rencontre
un homme
dont la fonction
première
est d'être
le médiateur
entre Dieu
lui-même
et toutes
les familles
de la terre
donc Abraham
pouvait avoir
une intuition
je ne sais pas
s'il l'a eu
à ce moment là
mais Abraham
pouvait avoir
une intuition
que la façon
dont sa descendance
allait bénir
les nations
ce sera que sa descendance
en fait
elle sera prêtre
comme cet homme
que je viens
de rencontrer
elle sera prêtre
du dieu
universel
la descendance
promise
elle aura
un office
sur toutes
les familles
de la terre
pouvait-il
imaginer
réellement
l'accomplissement
dans toute sa plénitude
de cette promesse
pouvait-il
imaginer
que des familles
le dimanche matin
issus
de toutes
les nations
de la terre
allait se réclamer
de la descendance
d'Abraham
publiquement
devant le monde
entier
pouvait-il imaginer
que la descendance
qui lui était
promise
allait être
du même office
que la personne
qu'il vient de rencontrer
après cette guerre
je ne sais pas
mais ce matin
nous pouvons voir
de par même
la composition ethnique
de notre église locale
comment Dieu
accomplit parfaitement
sa promesse
nous sommes
les fruits
du travail
du prêtre
du Dieu Très Haut
qui accomplit
ses promesses
de façon universelle
et le progrès
de l'évangile
dans les nations
qui a été annoncé
à Abraham
dans Genèse 12
est inévitable
c'est une promesse
unilatérale
de la part de Dieu
je bénirai
toutes les nations
de la terre
et dans toutes
les nations
de la terre
je retrouverai
des représentants
qui se réclameront
de ta descendance
Abraham
regardons-nous ce matin
contempler comment
Dieu est fidèle
à sa promesse
par ce prêtre
du Dieu Très Haut
et Satan
pourrait essayer
de se dresser
contre les promesses
de Dieu
que Dieu ferait même
usage de sa malice
pour continuer
à faire progresser
son royaume
à étendre son royaume
qui ressemble
à un arbre
qui s'étend
et dont les fruits
tombent parmi
toutes les nations
voilà comment est présenté
le royaume de Dieu
conquérant
triomphant
qui ne se limite pas
et c'est ainsi
qu'aujourd'hui
même en Chine
dans les villages
les plus reculés
c'est ainsi
que dans les tribus
les plus reculés
d'Afrique
l'évangile progresse
et les nations
se reconquises
à la seigneurie de Christ
à cause du prêtre
du Dieu Très Haut
nous qui venons tous
de nations païennes
avant que l'évangile
pénètre nos nations
et influence ses mœurs
qu'est-ce que nos nations
pratiquaient
moi qui suis
d'origine malgache
certains
d'origine rwandais
culte des morts
démocratie
culte des serpents
qui se baladent
dans la forêt
les sud-américains
parmi nous
magie
voudou
occultisme
païennes
des nations
qui n'ont rien
de différente
avec les nations
qui rentrent en jugement
contre Dieu
dans l'Ancien Testament
les français
de Souches
parmi nous
qui adoraient
dans les traditions
celtes
des pierres
qui étaient juste
plus grandes
que les autres
l'évangile
a conquis
ces nations
le prêtre
du Dieu
universel
accomplit
ses promesses
en faisant
usage
même des malices
et des événements
tragiques
de l'histoire
de nos pays
pour faire progresser
l'évangile
et cela
a déjà
été anticipé
dans cette rencontre
d'Abraham
qui reçoit
la promesse
et Abraham
qui rencontre
Cohen
Léalélion
le prêtre
du Dieu
très haut
aucun
sacerdoce
ni même celui
d'Aaron
qui semble si petit
à côté
de ce que Christ
est venu accomplir
de l'étendue
de son sacerdoce
et enfin
pour conclure
comment la
gloire singulaire
de Christ
peut être
revoir
dans cette rencontre
avec le prêtre
du Dieu
très haut
et Abraham
par la provision
excellente
du prêtre
du Dieu
très haut
nous avons vu
dans ce récit
que Melchisedec
se présente
à Abraham
avec du pain
et du vin
et c'était
une manifestation
ici de la
générosité royale
du roi
il vient pour
vivifier
des personnes
qui ont été
fatiguées
du combat
Abraham
et son peuple
sont partis
sués
fatigués
éreintés
de cette guerre
blessés
certainement
pour certains
d'entre eux
et ce type
de don
de pain
et de vin
c'est pas simplement
un bout de pain
et du vin
le roi
de Melchisedec
s'approche
avec générosité
avec en quantité
pour vivifier
pour donner
de la joie
maintenant
aux combattants
qui ont fini
leur combat
et voilà
comment
nous pouvons
dans ce passage
avec la bonne
compréhension
typologique
de Melchisedec
comme type
de Christ
et comme Abraham
qui représente
l'église
le père
de l'église
comment cette rencontre
vient figurer
la rencontre
d'une église
triomphante
avec son souverain
sacrificateur
l'église fatiguée
des combats
l'église
après les luttes
blessée
l'église
peinée
fatiguée
et bien
Dieu veut
réconforter
son église
avec la perspective
de notre
rencontre finale
avec notre
prêtre
Dieu
très haut
qui nous accueillera
les bras ouverts
aux portes du paradis
et qui nous accueille
pour les noces
de l'agneau
éternelles
pour nous donner
du repos
oui ce repos
nous pouvons le vivre
dès maintenant
mais Dieu nous annonce
qu'un jour
notre combat
sera terminé
vos larmes
seront effacées
vos peines
seront oubliées
oui Seigneur
je suis fatigué
de mon péché
fatigué de ce monde
en lutte
cela sera bientôt
terminé
vous allez rencontrer
le prêtre
du Dieu très haut
qui avec ses
victuales
viendra vous donner
la joie
pour l'éternité
il essuiera
de nos yeux
toute l'âme
voilà la provision
supérieure
de notre prêtre
et de la même façon
que la guerre
qui a eu lieu
on peut le dire
nous qui croyons
en la souveraineté
de Dieu
même les guerres
qui ont eu lieu
entre ces rois
ont été utilisées
dans la souveraineté
de Dieu
pour cette rencontre
d'Abraham
et de Melchisedec
nous pouvons dire
que Dieu fait usage
de nos luttes
et de nos combats
ici
pour réveiller
dans notre coeur
cette hâte
de rencontrer
notre Dieu
Maranatha
Jésus revient
les maladies
toutes sortes
de peines
cela sera oublié
lorsque nous rencontrons
Melchisedec
notre vrai prêtre
Jésus Christ
selon l'ordre
de Melchisedec
vos luttes
ont un but
et elles auront
une fin
et lorsqu'elles auront
vous célébrerez
la gloire
de la grâce
de votre prêtre
et contrairement
à Melchisedec
qui n'a pas pris part
au combat
Christ lui
prend part
à vos combats
Christ va
au-dedans
de vous
et Christ a déjà
même acquis
cette victoire
en votre nom
il nous demande
juste d'avancer
maintenant
avec confiance
dans une victoire
qui est déjà acquise
n'a-t-il pas dit
sur la croix
que tout est accompli
nous pouvons avancer
avec assurance
il combat pour nous
il l'a combattu pour nous
il nous attend
aux portes
de l'éternité
je ne l'ai pas vu
comme Abraham
n'avait peut-être
jamais rencontré
Melchisedec
vous n'avez pas encore
vu de vos yeux
votre sauveur Jésus Christ
mais vous le verrez
un jour
vous le verrez
dans toute sa gloire
et alors vous comprendrez
Pierre, Jacques
et Jean
vous comprendrez
les visions
de l'apocalypse
vous comprendrez
la gloire
qu'Ézéchiel
est en train
de décrire
dans des visions
si étranges
pour nous aujourd'hui
vous comprendrez
la stupeur d'Ésaïe
lorsque la gloire
de Dieu remplit le temple
nos yeux le verront
face à face
mes frères et sœurs
et non seulement
ce prêtre
annonce
une provision
supérieure à venir
mais il le fait déjà
dès à présent
il renouvelle nos forces
par tous les moyens
de grâce
qu'il a donné
à son église
combien la communion
fraternelle
est pour nous
un oasis le dimanche
après les péchés
après ce monde
difficile
après avoir
enduré la persécution
combien il est bon
de voir d'autres pèlerins
faire le même voyage
que nous
et chanter ensemble
debout
sainte cohorte
marchons jusqu'à
l'aurore ensemble
encourageons-nous
les uns les autres
combien lorsque mon âme
est pleine de peine
et de solitude
il est bon de retrouver
le miel
de la parole de Dieu
et de plonger mes regards
jusqu'à sentir
jusqu'à lutter avec Dieu
pour que Dieu me parle
et pour que Dieu
se saisisse à nouveau
de mon cœur
combien il est bon
dans ma solitude
de prier avec Dieu
jusqu'à ressentir
cette intimité personnelle
d'un Dieu avec moi
d'un Père avec moi
voilà les victuaires
que le Seigneur
notre prêtre
donne à son église
au milieu de ses combats
voilà ce que les hébreux
avaient besoin d'entendre
ils ont un prêtre
du Dieu très haut
un prêtre
dont la gloire
est incontestable
un prêtre
qui se propose
de pourvoir
d'une façon excellente
jusqu'à la fin
de leur combat
un prêtre
qui va les sauver
assurément
le prêtre
du Dieu très haut
Jésus Christ
lui-même
voilà ce que l'église
découragée
a besoin d'entendre
d'être renouvelée
dans la gloire
du prêtre
du Dieu très haut
pour que nous puissions
marcher avec assurance
n'ayez pas peur
de votre Dieu
chrétien
n'ayez pas peur
de votre avenir
chrétien
nous avons
le prêtre
du Dieu très haut
Amen